we would like to now apply the momentum
principle to examples of recoil so
recall that the momentum principle is
that the external force causes the
momentum of the system to change now
this is a vector equation so for example
if the external force in the x-direction
is zero then the momentum of the system
in the x direction let's say the final
momentum will be equal to the initial
momentum I would like to now apply the
momentum principle to an example of
recoil and in our recoil example we have
a person jumping off a cart so let's
just look at how this example can work
if we draw momentum diagrams so suppose
we choose a ground frame and in that
ground frame we have a cart and a person
person is standing on the cart and this
is T initial and here they are at rest
now the person we're going to assume to
jump horizontally off the cart and the
cart will recoil in the opposite
direction so after the jump we can
describe this picture the cart the
person is moving with a velocity V the
cart is moving with VC and the person
has jumped with the velocity VP now
suppose I choose a different reference
frame that instead of choosing a ground
frame as a reference frame moving
with the velocity VC you can imagine
that maybe I have a car here and that
car you're inside that car moving with
velocity VC and you're looking at this
picture then what would our momentum
diagrams look like well if I'm moving in
a car this way and in the ground frame
the initial picture is the person the
car is at rest that in my moving frame
it actually looks as if the cart and the
person are moving in the opposite
direction so let's write that this way
here's the initial picture T initial and
in this frame the person in the cart are
moving with VC minus VC I put an arrow
here to indicate that it's opposite the
direction of VC there but their velocity
is minus the velocity of the reference
right after the jump so here's the
person now the cart is at rest why
because we're in the reference frame
moving with VC so if you're in a car and
you're moving at the same speed that the
car has with the ground frame then in
your frame this car looks this cart
looks like it's at rest what about the
person jumping off
well that's let's write it this way so
this is the velocity I'm going to use a
symbol you now you this is what we mean
by that this is the velocity of the
person in the moving frame
that's moving with velocity BC that's
the velocity of the person as seen by a
card sometimes we call this the velocity
of the person relative to the cart what
does that word relative to the cart mean
well you could see in this picture in
this moving frame the cart is at rest
and the person jumps with a speed u
velocity u relative to the cart so these
are our momentum diagrams for a ground
frame in which the person in the cart
start at rest the person jumps off I can
put an arrow here but it's really
information is in that vector the cart
is moving in a frame moving with the
velocity of the cart
then what does my picture looks like
well the cart and the person initially
are moving opposite direction again
you're moving this way the cart looks
like it's moving that way if you're
inside the car and the final state
person cart is at rest and the person is
jumping with the velocity u relative to
the cart now our question now is how do
we relate these two velocities u and V P
what are u and VP VP is the velocity of
the person in the ground frame and U is
the velocity of the person in the moving
frame well we've already seen our
equation for how to get velocities in
different frames we have that DP equals
the relative velocity of the two frames
plus the velocity in the moving frame so
what we have is this is the velocity in
of the person we just clean that up of
the person
in the ground frame
V is the relative velocity of the two
frames so here we have that V is the
velocity of the cart because your inner
frame moving with VC with respect to the
ground and U is the velocity of the
person in the moving frame so this is
how we can show the same type of
interaction in two different reference
frames next we'll figure out what these
velocities are